I was sitting there talking with truly
and she's like well you and Mom are
divorced I'm like okay I didn't realize
it was a little bit news to me how is it
news to you that we're just divorced oh
we never made an official agreement we
never signed a paper we never agreed we
never went to our church leaders and
said hey we're divorced or we want a
divorce you know would they even allow
us a divorce all of a sudden it just
sank into me that she's just like ah I'm
leaving so we're divorced
usually our church would say your
divorce you have to go ask for a divorce
yeah yeah you have to get paperwork you
have to get approval you have to prove
that the marriage is broken
Christine just saying I'm divorce is
sort of invalidating
our beliefs we're spiritually married to
Cody by our church if we want a divorce
um then we have to go get their approval
usually they require counseling usually
they require lots and lots of like
meetings
you know technically from my
understanding until Christine is
physical with another man she's not
divorced
but I don't and I don't know
you know as far as I know
it's just that your divorce has to be
recognized but Christine has left the
faith so she says it'll be between her
and God and I'm like okay because the
rules don't apply to her anymore if
she's not in the faith
I was 19 when my mom left my dad and
left the plural family
she got a legal divorce because she was
legally married to my dad
and then she just left our church
so I since I don't have any legal
contract that binds me with Cody there
was no legal process that we've had to
go through
neither of us are part of that religion
anymore so me just saying I'm divorced
I don't see the problem in that at all
[Music]